okay hi everyone I'm going to talk to
you about exoplanets and I'm gonna talk
a lot about this mission test and tell
you how if you are interested you can
actually help find planets or study them
too so in April 2000 18 this NASA
mission it's an MIT led NASA mission
called test at launch on a falcon 9
rocket out of Cape Canaveral and it was
an incredible day it was so clear and
the plume was just so bright and our
whole mission that we had worked on for
about 10 years which isn't necessarily
all that long in the field but it was
like up in the tiny tiny top of that
saying going off into outer space and
test takes these incredibly beautiful
spectacular images of the night sky and
I'm going to tell you later how we
create time series of star brightness to
look for planets around other stars now
how many of you and actually what I am
gonna try to frame my talk around is
trying to answer the key questions that
I get asked most often and these are
people by all walks of life
like literally the type of person you
might meet on the subway bump into at
the conference like kids other people
and these are the questions now when I
get I'm gonna ask you to mull over which
one you think is the question I get
asked most often and I'll let you know
as I go through the questions so first
of all I was wondering how many of you
actually live in New York City and how
many of you have seen a truly dark sky
like a dead they're not necessarily
exclusive mutually exclusive well I
think you can still see a few stars from
New York City if it weren't for all the
tall buildings that get in the way
actually no you can still see a few
stars but the next time you look up at
the stars I want you to wonder what kind
of planet might be around that star
because it looks like all stars have
planets and we have found thousands of
planets orbiting other stars
but our Milky Way galaxy alone has
hundreds of billions of stars and so
there's probably trillions of planets in
our galaxy alone and so today I'm going
to try to give you something to walk
away with about what we know about
planets and how we're finding them and
where we want to go the first thing we
do of course is just put them on a plot
and this particular plot is it's on a
log-log scale so it's covering an awful
lot of ground and what you can see here
on this y-axis it's the size of the
planet
in terms of Earth radii and in astronomy
by the way we just normalize everything
so Earth is just one you one Earth radii
it's also one semi major axis unit
that's the distance from the Sun to the
earth and all these this is um all the
planet this is a large fraction of
planets we know and each dot represents
a planet around another star and each
color is from a different planet binding
technique so if you could read this plot
you'd see that some planets are over a
hundred times closer to their star than
more than our earth is to our Sun and by
Kepler's third law The Closer planet is
to the star the faster it goes around
some of these planets have a year the
time it takes to go around the star of
less than one day and some of these
planets that would be like earth size
their surfaces would be so hot they
would be covered in liquid lava lakes
not from volcanoes which is from the
heating from the star you also see at
the top end there are some planets um
and by the way Jupiter Neptune Earth are
on here some planets that these crazy
planets hot Jupiters we call them
because they're like Jupiter will there
Jupiter size and mass but they're so
close to the star and some of them are
so big like double the size of Jupiter
we don't really understand why it turns
out the most common type of planet is a
planet of two to three times the size of
Earth which by the way there are no
solar system counterparts were yet it
appears like it's the most common plan
no we don't know how they formed or what
they're made of really or anything so
there's a lot in this diagram I wish I
could unpack it further for you but um
can you guys will hear me okay okay but
what I do want to say is that so like
almost I'd say like 80% or more of
exoplanet work is done with Python even
to make this graph I just use um like
catalogs let you access them or you can
download data and use pandas and just
plot things and make cuts
now some planet finding techniques don't
measure a planet size and we only know
they only find a planet by their mass
and so someone made a program they call
it forecaster and it's literally just
one line of Python code to convert a
planet mass to size so I can put on this
plot for you the funny thing though is
it's based on a probability distribution
because there's no direct relation
between planet mass and size they seem
to come in all many sizes and masses
tons of orbits I hope you see from the
plot that it's almost totally full there
are some selection effects and some real
features that lead to clumping in this
plot but that was kind of my basic
introduction an exoplanet is a planet
that orbits a star other than the Sun we
don't know much about planets except
that they're there and their masses and
sizes and orbits but I still love to say
that in exoplanets anything is possible
within the laws of physics in chemistry
so now I'm gonna move on to the second
question when and how will we find
another earth that's what people want to
know we're nowhere near finding another
earth right right now we're working on
it
and just to tell you how hard it is it's
not so much that earth as another earth
would be hard to find it's not like
fainter than the faintest galaxies ever
observed by the Hubble Space Telescope
the problem is that an earth it's right
next to a big bright massive star and
the ways to find planets are based on
size mass or brightness it turns out our
earth is about a hundred times smaller
than our Sun our earth is about three
hundred thousand times less massive than
the Sun and it's ten billion times
fainter than the Sun and reflected light
so if you were gonna switch gears for a
while and look for planets which
technique would you choose would you
choose one that has to do with planet
size one that has to do with planet mass
or one that has to do with the planet
brightness okay it's not really a trick
question I mean my personal favorite
which I'm not gonna have time to get to
you in a sock but if you come to the
fireside chat I can talk more about it
actually is the 10 billion won which is
so hard and so hard hard to do but it's
the future now right now we're all doing
the easiest one because I think that's
what we do as humans we're doing the
easiest thing and the easiest one is to
use planet size and that's how like the
large majority of planets are found
today on the top can you see a planet
going in front of its star
that's the cartoon diagram of an
earthquake of sizes we don't spatially
resolve any star like that other than
our own Sun and at the bottom you see
the plot of the planet going in front of
the star it causes a tiny drop in
brightness and that it finishes going in
from the star and the star brightness
returns to normal
stars are like very very approximately
constant with brightness that's actually
not true as I'll come to later but in
general now I did cheat a bit because I
made it easy for you to pick
planet-sized it's really the area ratio
that makes the drop in brightness and so
that area ratio we have to square right
size and get area so our area ratio for
a true Earth twin is one part in 10,000
now I know here except for floating
floating point numbers and stuff you're
not so much worried about precision
probably like in engineering we build
things or if you build a deck at home or
well not if you live in New York City
that you you know you're not measuring
things to six or seven decimal places or
10 right you might measure it to one or
two decimal places so even doing
measuring a star's brightness to one
part in 10,000 is still really hard
so in exoplanets we go even further to
make our job easier we're mostly looking
for an earth-sized planet around a very
small type of star there are lots of
star types out there and most stars are
small not as small as the cartoon I'm
showing you I'm showing you a real image
of our Sun with some sunspots and with a
fake earth-sized planet and then the red
star is a very very very small type of
star it's actually the smallest type of
star in this relative size cartoon that
can exist any smaller the star would be
too cold on the inside too small to low
pressure to have fusion which is how we
define stars and I've actually put the
same cut and paste that same fake
earth-sized planet there and look how
much area takes out more area instead of
one part in 10,000 like for a Sun sized
star this earth-sized planet would only
take out one part in 100 for a small
planet and there's a lot of other
reasons why it's very favorable to find
planets around small stars which I don't
have time to get into too much of that
detail now but just take my word for it
that most of the exoplanet community is
kind of racing to find small planets
around small stars now one more thing I
forgot to mention is not all planets
transit their star because the planet
and star system have to be fortuitously
aligned so that the planet goes in front
of the star as seen from your viewpoint
imagine if there's a planet oriented
like this so the planet just orbits in
the plane of the sky it will never
transit and so it's just a geometric
argument because planets and stars have
just randomly oriented stellar axes and
and so it's really just a matter of
geometry so yeah so now I'm gonna switch
to tell you about the test mission and
how this MIT led NASA mission is finding
lots of planets here's a picture of this
mission from a couple years ago when it
was finishing being built I have the
people in this image they're in a clean
room and that's why they have these so
called bunny suits because dust and like
particles from your body and clothes
it's just bad for the telescope there
are solar panels there that were both
folded up before launch there is this
yeah that key helps us communicate with
earth each of these is a camera they're
actually housed in like a giant baffle
and the covers are just there they come
off before launch but they're just there
to protect the lens and each of the test
lenses will actually consume this baffle
here see how it's ribbed because stray
light from the Earth and Moon you don't
want it if it bounces inside your baffle
you don't want it then bouncing into the
lens and these ribs help limit the
amount of scattered light that hit your
actual lens the actual aperture of these
cameras it's only about this big ten
centimeters across and there's four
identical cameras and yeah so that's
that's the test mission I have a couple
of leg little movies to show you it's
like a beauty shot of Tesla Motors bases
and artist conception animation is
showing you that the cameras are aligned
in a way that they take up they met
observe a very giant strip of the sky
and this is showing you one camera it
has four detectors on it and it spans 24
degrees which and each camera is the
same it's actually a huge huge huge
amount of the sky and yeah I'm gonna see
and each of these parts of the sky we
look at for about a month
tiling the southern hemisphere night sky
which we've completed already and then
switching to the northern night sky
which comes next
these cameras really look at a lot of
stars about let's say millions of stars
per month we can't downlink all our data
to earth though like if I told you about
the memory storage and data rates you
would find it a bit sad for what you do
like onboard we store about 200
gigabytes
compressed and when it comes down at
about a hundred megabytes per second we
have a short window to download data
because Tess is in a very very highly
elliptical orbit about Earth we downlink
the data and uncompressed the data which
ends up being maybe closer to I said
wait hundreds of gigabytes several
hundred gigabytes to work with that's
how big a test camera is for those of
you that are familiar with the
constellation Orion it's like a huge
amount of data and here is a here's a
view of our H so we can't you can't see
it how beautiful it is really but this
is our first sector of data so each of
the four cameras you remember it's
taking on a giant strip they get spread
out here and this is actually satellite
galaxies of the Milky Way imagine it
clouds and there's a lot going on like
some stars are so bright they saturate
the detector and they create a blooming
effect but ultimately we want to make a
time series of brightness of each of
these objects I forgot to mention that
okay so our downlink rate is it's always
low for a space and so we been data
onboard the satellite and 20,000 like
choice target stars per month they get
been to two minute cadence and then the
rest of it is the full frame images like
all the data taken it's only been 2 30
minute intervals and that sound light so
I'm now going to walk you through how we
find planets and what we do is we have
to look at a star as it appears on the
image and we want to count up how bright
the star is in terms of how it registers
on the detector and do that for the
20,000 points per sector like per month
of data and this star by the way it's
not a point source you know by the time
it goes to the telescope optics it gets
spreads out over some number of pixels
because it's such a wide field stars
that get like sent to the edges of the
image they're often distorted in a
specific pattern bright stars like this
particular one is bright star it spreads
out it has this blooming effect word
that it kind of leaks out a bit and in
this postage stamp of data we call it
one of the choice 20,000 stars in this
particular sector we will like map out
like a box around the brightness of
these stars and literally just count
that up over and over again for every
image you just sum the brightness
and it turns out that the pixels it
changes with time so it's not like
uniform each time because the way that
spacecraft might be jittering sometimes
the stars themselves vary and a lot goes
on so we have to do this for a million
stars basically and here's what happens
if you count up that brightness as a
function of time this is showing you
time in days so this stands about 26 27
days and this is showing you the
brightness of the star relative ly and
the units are I know it seems weird but
it's part per million so we're looking
for small drops of brightness and this
is what we call the raw data it's not
like totally raw but it's mostly raw of
the images would have been calibrated
initially and I don't know if you can
see any transits here there are these
drops here they don't look like the
beautiful the pretty picture I showed
you before because they're compressed in
time a transit lasts a few hours and on
this scale of about a month they're just
all compressed in time but all of this
variation here it just is partly because
of what the spacecraft is doing and may
have to do with the Stars activity we
know what some of the effects are and
I'll go over one in a minute but when it
is sort of it's not even like a dirty
secret and astronomy but we will de tren
the data often without knowing the
physical effects I know a bunch of talks
I heard here you want to understand the
trends in your data because that's key
to your business here we don't really we
just want to get rid of the trends I
really wish we could understand all of
them there's one here we do understand
which I'll just tell you and this is the
first one of the first observations this
is like the first science data and this
is our first exoplanet that the mission
found and the mission operates much more
smoothly now but at the time where these
black lines are there were known events
we call momentum dumping when a
spacecraft is in space it has 2.4
exoplanets incredibly precisely just
like if you it's not like this but an
analogy is if you take a picture with
your camera it's shaking like the image
is just garbage
and because pixels like if you could
open your phone look at the detector
shine a laser at it move that laser
across each pixel and ask measure the
brightness that comes back at you it
actually varies by about 40 percent
across the pixel and so if that we're
varying here then the brightness we
measures back is a problem so the
spacecraft needs to point precisely but
there's a lot of forces moving it around
and there's reaction wheels that move to
balance out the
this motion of the spacecraft but as
those reaction wheels have to keep
working more and more and speed faster
and faster something will go wrong if
they speed too fast
and so occasionally you have to it's
called momentum dump you have to de spin
these wheels and you can fire thrusters
to do that or if you're in low-earth
orbit you can use the magnetic field but
you've got to come in and just like you
know let it go and that's what happened
here so the jitter would be getting bad
and bad things would happen and here
they would dump a momentum and then it
would change a little and then go back
down that's what those are these big
data gaps here are when Tess was down
linking data here there was some kind of
jitter problem so the person who made
this Chelsey who hang at MIT cut out
this data etc so we do tend the data and
then we get this curve there's still
some noise it's basically twice on
statistics plus a bunch of other stuff
and here I think you can see the
transits actually what she did was she
just fit a like I think she spit a sorry
spline with knots so something very
simple to just do Trent the data okay so
now what next we do is take this data
and face fold it because you can see the
repeating pattern of transits right and
so we'll just face hold the data and
make this what for this field is like a
beautiful plot this is a planet it's got
this great light curve where when the
planet this is the flux the brightness
change and this is time now in hours so
here's the star it's you know varying a
little there's some instrument noise and
then the planet crosses over the stellar
limb pretty quickly and now it's fully
superimposed on the star and now it
comes back out so that is the bottom the
basic way we find planets and I'm gonna
get into a little more detail on that
just in this part where I wanted to say
that you can find planets too I did like
a very big picture thing where you can
just google tests Python and you come to
this page it's like a at NASA they just
keep track of all the different tools
you can use to look at planets in the
archive I forgot to say that this test
mission by the way there's no
proprietary time because it's your
taxpayer dollars at work that funding
the mission and as soon as the data is
ready to go it gets put on a archive
called masked and anyone can access the
data so a lot of these tools involve
accessing the archive data
there's like spec there's tutorials on
these communities tools there's
literally like over 70 things you can
download but just like whatever field
you are in you don't want to just
download something blindly you need to
understand what it does I picked out a
really simple example to show you just
because I saw that people put some code
up and so you can see what we do is we
rely like numpy and pandas matplotlib of
course is key and here at the top of
this after we've imported what packages
we know there's the planet URL and this
Divi URL that's mass where things live
that's where all the data is archived
not just raw data calibrated data even
the light curves like the ones I've
showed you you can get those as well and
this simple code essentially you just in
here it's hard walk hard coded but here
there's a planet called wasp 18b and
yeah you can go down and do a lot of
things like looking in the database one
thing you do is you look for the
identifiers like what else is this
planet called wasp 18b is not a great
name but it's the survey that found the
planet got to name it but it also has
like ten other names just from catalogs
and other things and then you can kind
of go down and find out the planet mass
as encoded in the database other things
about it and eventually what's not on
here is you can just then pull up the
light curves and just look at them the
ones that are made now you might want to
analyze your own data and I just picked
another easy tool it's in the form of a
jupiter notebook but in this one it's a
code called light curve with a k' and
you could work through it
importing this package and then
searching for one and I picked the
example of the same star I already
showed you it's called pieman say it's a
bright star in a dark place you might be
able to see it just with your naked eye
without a telescope and here in this
jupiter notebook it's actually
explaining very clearly
maybe not clearly but there's a lot of
notes about what it's doing but
essentially remember your key is the set
of pixels that the star is lighting up
and so you have this thing called TPF
target pixel file and you can do various
things to it like you could find out
what its ideas in the test catalog you
can find out which sector it was
observed one which camera because
there's four cameras that's four which
of the detectors within that camera you
can choose your own like box around that
set of pixels and you can then like see
what numbers are associated with those
pixels and kind of relative brightness
and you can make a licker from it and
they picked this example that just had a
very simple way of choosing the aperture
this light curve actually is terrible um
compared to the ones I showed you before
it's the same star and look it's like
all over the place can you see any
trends it's here probably not so then
this code is kind of this Jupiter
notebook is walking you through what you
could do you could choose a better
aperture here it's trying to choose one
it says TPF create threshold mask
it's now saying as long as the pixels
are above some level of relative
brightness choose those pixels make your
mask so choose a different shape looks a
lot better now here's the part that if
you remember from before they we cut the
data out it's terrible the spacecraft is
jittering like crazy it's not really
usable other stuff is happening and you
can just in one line of code flatten the
slight curve get rid of some points get
rid of some outliers and eventually you
might phase fold the data and it doesn't
look as nice as the other plot but yeah
there it is there's your transit so you
could actually if you wanted to go to
some of these notebooks download some
code you could fool around because all
the data is archived when I was looking
through these to find a good example to
show you I then realized how much jargon
there is and so even though there'd be a
lot of jargon for people in the field
like going to school studying physics
studying math doing a bit of astronomy
the barrier to entry is really low now
thanks to Python it's very low you can
get in the field you can do data
analysis so I'm gonna continue telling
you about the planets in a bit of a
summary and then I'll go forward so our
goal is our steps rather we want to
construct a time series of star
brightness for either each star of
interest or for all of the stars we need
to de tren the data then what we do what
I didn't show you is we run a search
algorithm based on facehole de data so
we take each you know stream of data and
we fold it on every face possible at
every period possible looking for a
signal that looking to see if there's a
sick
in Fourier space then after we do that
we can compute some computer-generated
metrics to abusive Planet candidate list
our computer sort through all these
planet candidates we do use machine
learning which I'll talk about in a
moment we use just like algorithms that
are more like brute force and eventually
everything spits out let's say a hundred
objects or a few hundred objects per
sector that humans actually look at to
figure out which ones are worthy of
being deemed a planet candidate and we
do actually believe it or not every
Tuesday and Thursday so it would be
about right now the team meets at MIT
between 1:00 and 3:00 to look through
these planet candidates and see which
ones deserve to go out to the community
to be followed up with other
measurements to see if they're actually
planets okay so that's a lot so I want
to show you some of these metrics even
though I don't have time to explain them
in all detail I thought you might like
to see some of them so for everything
that gets flagged as a repeating signal
that might be like a transit this is a
summary like sometimes there's reports
that are like dozens of pages we have
five page summary we have one page
summary and here at the top it's showing
you the D trended time series data so
this is in days and this is again
relative brightness but looks like the
units are missing and here these blue
triangles tell you where the transit is
this panel will be the face folded data
this would be zoomed in a face holder
data so that one looks like the plots
I've been showing you we have some other
key information which are is the
auxilary data we use to tell whether
it's a planet or not we have a lot of
stuff you'd be amazed with what kind of
what stars are doing out there here's
one it might look like a transit but in
fact it's an eclipsing binary star two
stars are orbiting each other as is very
it looks like it there's hardly any
noise in this data but it's just because
the signal is so big it's just very
clear it has this V shape because as two
stars Eclipse each other they never
cleanly go over the stellar limb it's
sort of like very gradual because you've
won a big star going in front of another
star it's taking out a different area
like it each step it's not never
superimposed on the star we have other
things like variable stars some of these
stars are pulsating like a heartbeat
they're just unstable there's one at the
bottom that's
incredibly pulsating a lot there's some
really pretty things it's sort of like
flipping through a picture but sometimes
in the early days we looked at all our
data I'm sure it's the same for you like
if you work in industry like you've got
to look at your data and understand it
you don't want to just throw it at a
black box computer code and it was just
amazing to see all the gorgeous things
that are just happening on this repeated
time scale this one at the bottom is
probably some kind of star spots where
the star is changing slowly over a
number of days as it rotates must have a
lot of spots covering the surface this
one is actually a binary star that's
orbiting but it's gravitationally
distorting each other because they're so
close together causing like this
continuous change in brightness so I
wanted to give a few remarks about
artificial intelligence and
planet-finding because of course as soon
as you have a big data set that's what
you wanted that's you know what you want
to do the tools we face some unique
challenges but I'm showing you this plot
here which is one of the only two
planets genuinely found by machine
learning in exoplanets and I want you to
look at the y-axis for a moment so
remember the bottom axis is ours from
mid transit so the transit lasts about
an hour or two and that y-axis is drop
in brightness and look how tiny that is
it's incredible this is a tiny planet
it's about the size of Earth oh remember
what I said before that Earth going from
the Sun would be one part in 10,000 this
is like pretty much that looks like
close to one part in 10,000 and what's
interesting here this was taken not with
the mission I've been describing but
another one called Kepler that's now
retired and here the authors use a deep
convolution neural network and it
managed to sift through a ton of data to
identify this one as a planet candidate
there's tons and tons of every pretty
much I'd say many many algorithms you'd
be familiar with have been tried for
planets finding we have a few major
problems which I want to mention mostly
machine learnings used as a
classification tool there's only one
case in exoplanets where it has been
used to do something you couldn't do any
other way
so I don't know for you folks but I
don't know if I feel like happy or sad
when it's sophisticated algorithms are
only used to classify but in the case of
this planet on the screen it had to be
because
a lot of the faint targets there's just
too many to sort through brute force or
other conservative traditional methods
there's one case where a planet was
found kind of triggered on because the
he's opposed talking on my team named
Jason tippmann what he did was it was a
ground-based search and he used weather
data taken up the site where the
telescope is and used that as input to
the neural network and was able to
Decorah late database from our
atmosphere to find a planet transit okay
so most people your problem is the
limited training set here for planets we
feel like we have a lot I said there's
like 4,000 on planets like that's not
really that many especially because
they're found by a lot of different
techniques in tests for example we've
got 30 confirmed planets right now
that's not enough to train on we need
simulated data which you might want to
use but even in this paper that found
the planet I'm showing you they found
out that they could never perfectly
simulate a planet in a real planet in a
light curve even introducing the planet
of the image level so we're still
working on how to make a simulated data
set given that we don't have enough
training data our next problem is
non-uniform labeling all these beautiful
things I showed you before by the way we
no longer label them we used to classify
and like label everyone initially by
humans in our first couple months of
data and then by we don't even bother we
just throw them out now because we're
not interested them so we really miss
label data we right now have an activity
where humans are gonna go through like
20,000 light curves and hand label them
but that's that's our problem - the
other thing is that gaps in the data I
showed you the light curves you know
there's a lot of gaps you know some
algorithms else jams and gans they don't
like gaps so we've got to fill those
gaps in and that may skew things as well
finally each of these different months
these sectors of strips of the sky each
of them Tess has different noise
properties so when we train like on a
certain a few months then we want to
find planets in another few months we
kind of run into problems so yeah that's
where we are but there's lots people
working on this we hope we make progress
we can always resort to brute force so
right now as of like today we have
almost 1,400 planet candidates from six
in observing sectors we've got 400
planets smaller than Neptune 30
published planets I forgot to give you
some numbers like out of milk well we
have millions of stars we look through
we get let's say thousands 10,000
triggered planet transits that planet
like transits that crossed the threshold
and we whittle that down to just dozens
of objects so this is gonna end like my
data analysis portion of the talk but I
wanted to know zoom out and tell you a
few other things now what we learn from
this is we learn the planet size because
remember the planet goes in front of the
star and a star dropped some brightness
by an amount related to the planet to
star area ratio so if we know the size
of the star we have the drop in
brightness we get the size of the planet
we know the planet orbit because we see
a periodic transit and by Kepler's law
third law we also know the distance of
the planet from the star we know
something about the star properties
already and so we'll know how very
roughly the temperature of the planet
because the light from the star energy
from star hits the planet and heats it
up and those are what we know about lots
of planets sometimes we know the planet
mass it's already exists in in archived
data with a different technique or we
follow it up for that we know something
oh the planet density other planets in
the same system but we really want to
know a lot more so I'm gonna go back to
the question that this part of the talk
was supposed to address which is when
will we find another earth and so just
to remind you we can't we're looking for
these small planets around small stars
on the whole in tests we may have like
one maybe but it takes a long time to
follow up these small planet candidates
and to confirm them as planets so I
wanted to shift gears slightly and take
you on like a virtual trip to a planet
orbiting a small star these small stars
are very red they give off very low
energy compared to our Sun and so the
planet if we could go there the plate if
we go to that planet the star or the Sun
might be very big in the sky because
just like a campfire it gives off at
small fires giving off a tiny amount of
energy you'd have to stand really close
to that fire to stay warm so the planets
have to be very close to these small red
dwarf stars to have the right
temperature this artists just chose to
make the
sky red instead of blue and clouds
purple we can actually make some guesses
as to what the colors will be but our
data i'm planted atmospheres is so
limited we can't say for sure in this
case because i said this like three or
four times already but the planet close
to the star it goes around much more
quickly and so on planets like this a
year would last just a few days actually
so you couldn't have this conference
evidence of days that would just be
insane maybe they would operate in
centuries on that planet so what's
really interesting about the planets
close to the star is due to tidal
interaction with the star over millions
of years the just like you know we have
tides on earth the moon has we raise
tides on the moon it turns out that the
planet ends up in its lowest energy
state which is it rotates one time for
every time it orbits it's like one day
also equals one year which is kind of
weird and our Moon which I know you can
see from New York it always shows the
same face to earth it actually library
it's a little so you get a bit of a bit
extra but it's it's rotating one time
for every time it orbits the earth what
this would mean if we can go to the
planet is this the star or the Sun would
be in the same place in the sky at all
times so you could choose to go there
it's always day or you might want to go
where it's always night or where the Sun
is always setting so on the other hand
visiting this planet might be a terrible
idea because these stars the red dwarf
stars they actually give off like giant
flares so you couldn't be having your
phone all the time because the
high-energy rays from these flares would
knock out your electronics you're
worried about UV radiation and stuff I
don't know what it would do to your
scanner your your cancer-causing yeah it
may not be good at all and so we're not
really sure like on the one hand
remember I asked at the beginning who
wants to find planets by their size like
we're doing the easiest thing but it may
not be the right thing necessarily you
don't really know and so on our earth we
had a our Sun actually also gives off
flares and here's a real image of our
Sun in just a very narrow wavelength
range so it shows up a little strange
looking and these flares sometimes give
off mass mass so the Sun sometimes comes
off and there's this event in the 1850s
called the Carrington
have any of you heard of the Carrington
event okay great so we have it was so if
you want to have like something to worry
about you can worry about this because
when this part of our Sun came off by
the way back then astronomers were just
studying sunspots Maxwell's equations
that describe electricity magnetism
weren't articulated yet but a day and a
half after this astronomer called
Carrington saw sunspots and our Sun
brighten our earth became electrified it
turned out you could see Northern Lights
almost of the Equator people there
weren't power grid back then but there
are telegraph operators and Telegraph's
which when they took the battery out
they operate on their own power some of
them caught fire telegraph lines got
fire what happened with is a small part
of the Sun had an embedded magnetic
field and it came hurtling towards Earth
it hit our magnetic field and induced
the current essentially so if that
happened today I think we well not just
think I mean we people do think about
this we would be in big trouble because
our entire power grid would probably
collapse here so that's kind of bad news
I just want you to know that I go into a
bit of an extreme on this case because
when I get asked that question how will
I find another earth you know it's not
the actual truth twin we're gonna be
able to look for right now
in the next decade let's say we're gonna
fast-track by searching small stars
fourth cousins instead of Earth twins
we're gonna use transits the most
favorable planet finding technique for
small planets so that's kind of where
things are going in the field right now
and don't continue on now can we go
there so in case you were wondering
which question I get asked most often
this is the question actually can we go
there you probably know the answer
here's a picture of our Sun any guesses
as to how big earth would be compared to
this Sun it's yeah the size of the Sun
SPOT on this it's actually real sunspot
on this the next question is is how far
like if this is the size of our Sun
where do you think earth would be
physically located just for scale it
turns out that just by again astronomers
we'd like to round everything off but
our earth is about a hundred Suns away
from our Sun so you take this and like
count to 100 so it would probably be
like let's see I forget what all the
room
are called but it's somewhere pretty far
so the next question is if this was the
size of our Sun how far away do you
think the next star is yeah New Jersey
okay yeah so it's pretty much as far as
you could get it so be in the
continental US fart the the source in
kind of this neck of the woods they're
very far apart and our fastest
spacecraft right now with the well the
voyagers spacecraft are among the
fastest and they are leaving our solar
system our solar system they're going
about 20 kilometres a second and it
would still take them tens of thousands
of years to get tour near a star so if
you just sort of think of those numbers
can we go there not for now okay but
there's a but that I want to tell you
about because like one of the great
things about exoplanets I mean we still
do all the data analysis and you do what
we call big data for our amount of data
we have data fusion we do you know
machine learning but the line between
what is considered mainstream and what
is considered crazy is constantly
shifting and this year the Nobel Prize
in Physics went to exoplanets whereas 20
years ago even when I started working in
the field it was really fringe like
people didn't take it seriously they
didn't believe they were planets and so
now people are thinking about how could
we get to the nearest stars and there's
a concept called star shot and they call
it a star chip instead of starship and
the goal here you can look this up
actually it's by the breakthrough
organization they just have these little
tiny chips and to launch tens of
thousands of them just like how nature
like when the baby turtles are born
there's a lot of them because they're
not all gonna make a hit so the idea is
to put these little chips up launch them
into low-earth orbit and by the way the
story gets a bit crazier but the
organization is really good because they
list their 19 biggest challenges so you
don't have to you know do it for them
and say okay they're gonna go to space
and deploy about a 1 meter sail and then
a big bank of telescopes on the ground
very powerful like a hundred gigawatt
power over all will literally shine on
these space sails and accelerate them to
about 20 percent the speed of life like
that's the goal and they could get to
the nearest star in about 20 years just
to that so I thought actually their
biggest challenge I know there's a lot
of technical challenges involved like
how not to you know evaporate the little
sail or the big sail
I actually thought the biggest challenge
was getting the land here cuz like where
would you get what they need is like a
square kilometer of land and a hundred
gigawatt power you know like a hundred
watt light bulb they need a billion of
those because stuff like above it would
be but they actually do they're in the
process of hopefully getting land and I
want to say it's New Zealand or
Australia next to like an old power unit
so it may actually happen if it may
actually happen but I just saying that
this helps shift that line so the
follow-up question that'll get is if we
can't go why look and I'm getting to the
last part of my talk well we actually do
what we call remote sensing we have
telescopes like the Hubble Space
Telescope we have an upcoming telescope
it's called the James Webb Space
Telescope
um there's tests by the way we like to
joke that test is like the planet finder
for the James Webb Space Telescope which
we hope to use to observe exoplanet
atmospheres on the ground now we're
building or trying to build the next
generation telescopes like the giant
Magellan telescope and others these are
twenty meters in diameter up to 40
meters in diameter and what we're going
to do is study planet atmospheres so
just for a bit of physics 101 when you
think of a rainbow its sunlight split up
into its colors but what you might not
know about the rainbow is that there are
little tiny pieces of color that are
missing and here's the rainbow made by
an instrument inside a telescope called
a spectrograph and this is of our Sun
and you can see there's little pieces of
color missing where it turns out this is
our sun's atmosphere is absorbing atoms
and our sun's atmosphere and some of
them may be our Earth's atmosphere or
absorbing radiation so I'd like to say
that the atmosphere takes a bite out of
the spectrum but here to a seller
spectroscopy this they would know what
each of these lines is what atom it
corresponds to what electron transition
and we actually look at graphs and plots
but I just want to show you this one
because it's more easily understandable
and you can see how some lines are
really thick and dark other lines are
really narrow and thin but we try to
piece this together based on quantum
mechanics of which molecules and atoms
observed in which part of the spectrum
and piece together everything that's
going on in EXO in atmospheres we're not
there yet for EXO
it's we've observed like dozens of
atmospheres of hot Jupiter planets but
we need those next generation space
telescopes to get down to smaller planet
atmospheres so we do need these spectra
because in the transit method I told you
about by the way if there's an
intelligent civilization looking back at
us with a test space mission or
something more sophisticated they can't
tell the difference between Venus and
Earth and our planet Venus it's so hot
it's close to our Sun but it has a giant
greenhouse atmosphere its surface is so
hot it's like hundreds and hundreds of
degrees hotter than our surface it's hot
enough to melt lead on a surface of
Venus so we need to see the atmosphere
to evaluate the greenhouse gases and see
how hot the planet is we also want to
see gases like water that indicate
liquid water oceans needed for all life
as we know it
we have gases like oxygen that we all
require to live that oxygen on our
planet it's made by plants and
photosynthetic bacteria but without
plants without life-forms that can do
photosynthesis we would have virtually
no oxygen in our atmosphere so we're
looking for gases that don't belong and
we actually make complicated models of
atmospheres of planets this is based on
like decades of physics and applied
physics and Earth's atmosphere and I
don't really have too much to say about
it right now
there is a lot of opens forth Python
codes for it by the way but the entry
level is still really high because you
need to know the physics behind
atmospheres and oftentimes I'm sure this
applies for your your work as well but
often times you'll download you want to
just download a code and use it but it
actually doesn't do what you need it to
do doesn't like reach out in parameter
space that you require so I just have a
couple minutes left to talk about I know
I had to leave my favorite project to
the end because it was too complicated
and new to really articulate but we want
to know in the future when we get
exoplanet atmosphere data of small rocky
planets
I don't hate to miss a sign of life
because we didn't know what we were
looking for and so my group we embarked
on this project of trying to evaluate
every molecule that can be at gas form
at room temperature and pressure and
sort through each of them to figure out
if any of them should be on our menu of
options of things to look out for or
purposely try to look and this pot is
showing you just a bunch of molecules
is what we call chemical space just like
space is defined by stars and galaxies
chemical space is a space spanned by all
possible molecules for small organic
molecules there could be like 10 to the
60 of them for all organic molecules to
be like 10 to do 200 molecules I don't
think there's any talks on drug
discovery here but this is there's like
a whole field that does this actually
and so in our case we want to sort
through chemical space just in a way
that's useful for exoplanet atmospheres
and bio signature gases and we do have a
way to filter them this is like a shaker
filter you're imagining that you have
thousands tens of thousands of molecules
you need to sort them out in some way to
find out which are never made by life
which might be made by life and might be
useful on an exoplanet and I want to say
that the one thing that made our life so
much easier is that there's this open
source chemo informatics software it's
called Rd ket and that like none of you
heard of it that it actually because to
describe a molecules it's sort of kind
of complicated because there's a lot of
redundancy there could be a lot of like
mix-up unless you can describe it really
clearly and this code has been super
useful for trying to sort through these
large classes like all these molecules
so I hope I've convinced you that
there's a lot going on exoplanets that
Python really helps with quite a lot of
it and in many cases like tremendously
lowers the barrier to getting to work on
exoplanets so to summarize the questions
I get asked most often what is an
exoplanet it's a planet that orbits a
star other than the Sun when and how
will we find another earth I actually
you know if we find another earth that
has been found by the transit method
you'll not only know how how it was
found you would actually be able to go
and download some tools and if you
wanted to like learn exactly how it was
found we can't find an earth around the
Sun right now so we can't find an earth
around the Sun that we're able to follow
up and look at its atmosphere so our
fast track is to look for these small
planets that transit small stars can we
go there not for now but I want to tell
you that in exoplanets like this seed is
planted for the future of trying to
figure out how we might get there and if
we can't go there why look because we
can use sophisticated telescopes for
remote sensing to search for water and
signs of life in
small rocky temperate planets thank you
for your attention
[Applause]